a
[Música]
ah
la vacuna rusa sputnik v se comercializa
en más de 60 países aunque todavía no en
europa el presidente ruso ha acusado a
la unión europea de estar tardando en
aprobar la vacuna rusa contra el
coronavirus debido a una batalla por el
dinero
por cierto que antes de que acabe el mes
podría haber veredicto de la
organización mundial de la salud sobre
la vacuna es público pronto rusia puede
convertirse en un nuevo destino para el
llamado turismo de vacunas recientemente
vladimir putin ha invitado a los
extranjeros a dejar a rusia para
vacunarse y ha ordenado al gobierno ruso
que cree las condiciones necesarias para
que esto seguirá a cabo mientras la
unión europea se decide en países como
serbia y hungría ya han optado por la es
pública y por ejemplo argentina ha
empezado a producirla y brasil tras
algunas dudas la ha aceptado
putin cree que los aplazamientos en el
registro de la vacuna en europa están
vinculados con estos intereses
comerciales de los fabricantes porque
así ganan tiempo frente a los
competidores en muchos ámbitos cuando
los rusos tengan luz verde será ya un
poco tarde para vacunar
[Música]
algo más de 300.000 dosis del componente
1 de sputnik b fueron las primeras
vacunas contra kobe 19 que llegaron a
argentina el 24 de diciembre de 2020 un
día después de que fuera aprobada en el
país que después de bielorrusia fue el
segundo en el mundo en aprobar esa
vacuna fuera de rusia y el primero en
américa latina' en su momento la
decisión generó controversia porque
todavía no se habían publicado los
resultados de los estudios en fase 3 de
la vacuna sputnik pero con el tiempo se
publicaron nuestros resultados y la
vacuna demostró ser eficaz desde ese
primer envío y hasta este martes ya
llegaron al país más de 9 millones 400
mil dosis de esa vacuna además argentina
es el primer país de américa latina que
integra la cadena de producción de
sputnik ve el laboratorio local ritmo
dónde está comenzando el filtrado
formulado y envasado de unas 480.000
dosis del componente 1 luego de que este
martes llegarán desde rusia 300 litros
del principio activo de la vacuna
[Música]
brasil supera su desconfianza y permite
ahora la importación de la vacuna rusa
aunque con limitaciones recordamos que
en abril la agencia nacional de
vigilancia sanitaria había prohibido
esta vacuna por considerarla poco segura
ahora de forma excepcional permite que
los gobernadores de los estados del
noroeste de brasil importen unas dosis
eso sí tendrán que responsabilizarse de
todas las posibles complicaciones y
hacer un seguimiento de cerca otra
limitación se refiere a la cantidad de
vacunas permitidas
los gobernadores querían importar 30
millones de dosis ahora sólo podrán
comprar el equivalente al 1% de la
población de los estados donde gobiernan
además no podrán ser vacunadas personas
menores de 18 años mayores de 60 tampoco
las personas con enfermedades crónicas y
las mujeres embarazadas se prevé que las
primeras dosis lleguen a brasil en el
mes de julio
[Música]